he's a paradox I run into with these
kind of movies I'm always like rich
people are dicks but I still want to be
rich all the money in the world so all
the money in the world's directed by
Ridley Scott it starts Christopher
Plummer is john paul Getty that
originally Christopher Plummer it was
gonna be Kevin Spacey in fact the movie
was finished filming and it was Kevin
Spacey we got a trailer we had a big
rubber mask and we found that Kevin
Spacey was a dick and they were like I
think we can film all the Christopher
Plummer scenes in like 10 days and they
did it and Christopher Plummer has his
real face not a rubber mask as you
wonder why they didn't just cast
Christopher Plummer in the first play I
don't know when he's in the 70s John
Paul Kelly was the richest man in the
world and his grandson was kidnapped and
the kidnappers were like we want 17
million dollars and he was like I know
so this movie is about that kidnapping
the mom played by Michelle Williams
wants to get her son back but she
doesn't actually have that money that
money is the grandfather's money jump
all getting he just ain't budging on the
matter what I like most about this movie
let's just bring it on is Christopher
Plummer Christopher Plummer is awesome
he's amazing you would never know this
movie was intended or actually finished
filming with Kevin Spacey or anyone else
you would think from start to finish it
was like yeah it was always Christopher
Plummer right and he's awesome as john
paul Getty when I saw the trailer and
you see Kevin Spacey's delivery up the
line where he's all nothing and you see
Christopher plumbers where he's like
nothing I was like unpopular opinion
like Kevin Spacey's delivery better this
is one lines one word doesn't matter cuz
it all goes out the window when you see
Christopher Plummer own this role he's
what you were going to remember and talk
about from this movie the movie does a
great job illustrating the disconnect
that happens when you have that much
money you have so much money you don't
need to worry about the concerns that
other people in the world have he's want
for nothing it is in fact like you're on
another planet when you're like that
it's like you're a different species so
when they're like 17 million dollars to
save a life that's your grandchild he's
like no this movie does illustrate how
someone could do that or be like that as
monstrous and weird as it is for most of
the rest of us to actually comprehend
but in the end the movie falls short on
a lot of other aspects I mean the set up
kind of bored me I wasn't connected with
any of the characters what was happening
was a kid was kidnapped the
grandfather's a rich disconnected dick
who won't pay the ransom and the mom
really wants to pay the ransom you would
think that would make for some awesome
moments of tension between the two but
here
kind of dodges her calls in her meetings
so it's just like you are in fact
watching history play out and it's like
you're watching events that sound really
interesting on paper but actually in
film it's not really as interesting
that's that there aren't interesting
things in it not that there aren't
interesting characters in it one of the
most compelling characters in the entire
movie other than Christopher Plummer
who's awesome is the main dude who first
kidnapped a kid I thought they added
some complexity with him but the rest of
the movies kind of bogged down it's like
kidnapping happened we're getting to the
endgame he's got to see all the
information play out in between to get
there it's like they were like all right
the true story of the kidnapping of the
grandson of the richest man on earth
what happened in that event well not
much not much at all but we got to fill
a couple hours something happens about
halfway through possibly two-thirds of
the way through rosary oh hey here we go
it looks like it's gonna actually get us
there but if you've bored me for the
first half or two-thirds the last act
isn't gonna actually bring it home for
me you've already kind of lost me at
that point and the visual appeal of the
movie the movie just looks like it was
filmed through muddy [ __ ] I've never
liked this color palette they used in
this movie I see it in other movies that
are supposed to be dramas usually
historical dramas like the colors are
there you know what they're supposed to
be but it kind of looks like this it's
just not as interesting as the natural
color scheme of the world it's like the
movies being told through an Instagram
filter if the Instagram filter was
actually named boring guys in the end
all the money in the world had enjoyment
most of that enjoyment is Christopher
Plummer he carries this movie he's
actually entered a lot more than I
thought he'd be in the back they were
like I think we can refill all the
scenes in ten days it's an interesting
story to tell it's a story that should
be told people of good moments here and
there I'm just not gonna remember this
movie as one of the movies of 2017 maybe
we'll be shown in classrooms but for me
I'll say all the money in the world
would probably be a better time if
you're drunk yeah no it's a boy all
right guys so all the money in the world
have you seen it what did you think
about it or what did you think of
Christopher Plummer in here whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]